we got it all plugged in to me do we
have everything look at it so cold we
have everything plugged in mm-hmm now is
the moment of truth we hit the power
button and see and see if all of our
hard work has been worth it huh what's
up everybody I'm here with Kim today
from UI a solutions out of Utah we're
gonna do something really really cool
today they hit us up hey
seems like you guys could use some
server help which is true I'm going to
build you a file server but it's a
special type of processor you have an
increased bandwidth and you can kind of
scale it up infinitely so your
bottleneck no longer becomes the server
it becomes your workstations and the
storage Thomas here he goes fascinating
one the original reason I reached out to
corridor was because as I saw last fall
their raid failed yeah I bailed and the
server lets us utilize 10y let's say 100
Gig file we'll take X amount of time
will be 10 down is faster what why
envision is to use that as a primary
storage and yes as a backup that's great
does that mean I can stop deleting Sam
and Nico footage
[Applause]
[Music]
okay what's up with all that that
thermal packaging over on the other one
because that's about 70 pounds and this
is about like 30 oh I don't know about
you but that look like a table I can
support seventy pounds yeah always boys
building bill see and I thought it would
be all about technology and computers no
instead we have to do manual labor so
now we need to put the server on you
think this is a two-man this thing gonna
save your bad [ __ ] Spencer we're
talking about I have to carry around 200
pounds everywhere I go 70 extra - this
is a hot swappable power supply there
are certain certain brands that require
you have their specific brands
connection cables so for here for here
we have an HP HP n so HP's requiring you
to have the HP cable or what's to call
them the SFP SFP otherwise what happens
it doesn't work it essentially it could
it can either a turn off your switch to
save all the ports or just not work into
the hot swappable power supplies so
here's both of them they're really
efficient lookup small exam is 350 watts
for this one platinum now is the moment
of truth we hit the power button and see
and see if all of our hard work has been
worth it
[Music]
Lucas come again this is little stands
oh my god what's going Skynet Ronnie's
gonna switch it over I think that's a
great idea
Kim you just made us so legit so you ie
Kim came along and they said hey we can
probably provide a solution to you guys
that allows you to scale as you grow do
this already for small businesses big
businesses across the world and
nationwide did that work I wear for the
flops in the office because that's just
how I roll and Ren wears is one wheel in
the office that's literally just how he
rolls and whenever he's rolling by me
I'm always worried about my toes so I
made a rule and that is any time I hear
the one wheel hit the ground hard
usually meaning somebody fell off they
put a dollar in the beer jar Louis the
guy who actually made this we decided to
take one of our Nerf darts we're all
signing it we're gonna mail it to him
hopefully it'll fit in like an envelope
so even will said that they made that
gun but the thing is guys we knew who
was immediately you just tell yourself
he also sent us an email with pictures
there's that last week I got an email
from a company called sumo sumo makes
large luxurious beanbag chair slash
couches slash beds
I guess the huge they're like bean bags
for Giants but my understanding is that
it's all tightly packed together and
when you open this that they will
breathe life into itself and expand them
to the size of a giant beanbag chair
we're gonna watch it expand and we're
gonna sit on it and see if it's soft
here we go
it's a so it's a bunch of foam pellets
and they're all compacted down in a
vacuum as air gets into this they expand
come on I got open it now before it
expands too much they can't open it
anymore
come on zipper come on come on you can
do it there's a little back I think I
got plastic stuff in it too Oh
puncture the plastic no I'm pulling the
zipper so hard I'm moving myself weight
hundred would be switch plastic jammed
up this guy and you allow me like as she
comes up in a zipper
it's a bad idea I should not be getting
a speck there's no way I can get this
zipper unstuck
[ __ ] hey [ __ ] this ups are do prayer
doesn't is if reopen by hitting with the
hammer
let's get in there good choices make bad
stories oh man
look it was plastic I have stuck in the
zipper
it's expanding so fast oh it's off pigs
are really comfy really soft this one is
not full yet it's a little lumpy right
now I look forward to being fully
inflated the other way quick move eat
that process